we strum with a little rap will
minimalist rap we are the minimalists
and we're here to say here's our two
cents take it or leave it
something that rhymes with say there's
so much the rhymes will say you can't
think about like orange we are the
minimalist in here's our orange go ahead
and clear out all of your storage
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
[Music]
hey y'all some exciting news before we
dive into this episode the minimalists
are going to host a private podcast and
live stream exclusively for our patreon
supporters we're calling this ask the
minimalists anything anyone who
contributes 2 dollars or more over at
our patreon page can attend this special
livestream if you can't make the
livestream itself the live session the
live podcast don't worry you'll still
have access to the private video and the
private audio podcast after it's
recorded we hope to do this at least
once a quarter maybe more frequently for
our patreon supporters and please note
that none of the money from our patreon
campaign goes to our personal bank
accounts rather what we're going to do
is use these funds to build our own new
podcast studio and a film studio we're
just going to allow us to do a bunch of
really cool things like take live
callers on the air improve overall audio
quality and bring guests on the show
we're also going to hire a full-time
filmmaker to create a video version of
this podcast and we also want to produce
a bunch of other meaningful video
creations like webseries TV shows
interviews documentaries video essays
and more and because we refuse to
clutter our podcasts with advertisements
patreon really is the best way for us to
fund these creative endeavors together
so let me ask you this are you willing
to help if so please become a patron
today head on over to patreon comm slash
the minimalists or you can go to our
website it's just the minimalists comm
and click on the donate button at the
top we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well and please know that your
support is greatly appreciated together
we will create something meaningful
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I am Ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist and we are back we
are back well we haven't gotten anywhere
for you all you're still getting your
your weekly episodes we've been on the
road and hopefully you're enjoying those
it's been a whole lot of fun we're
halfway through the lessons now tour
we'll talk about that in a moment
but welcome to episode number 91 today
we're specifically going to talk about
nostalgia and I wrote an essay recently
Ryan about nostalgia and we already had
a bunch of questions about nostalgia so
Sean picked out podcast Sean here he
picked out our the three the three best
questions and we're going to answer some
of those today but first we're going to
move our right here right now segment to
the beginning because we're adding a new
segment to the podcast that was
recommended by our friend Malcolm Fon
Thea what it's called weightlifting with
the minimalist and we'll get to that and
well toward the end of this podcast but
because it's been such a long time Ryan
we have a lot to talk about we we've
been we've been doing a lot of things
you've been you've been in Germany yes
it was awesome yeah man you spent like
almost a month over there oh yeah we got
there on July 9th and came back on the
29th so it was just about three weeks
and it was worth it man it was so you're
all over the place over there you even
hosted a little tweet up I did yeah I
wanted to do one a Munich but I did not
find the time but Mariah and I we were
in Berlin for like four or five days and
first of all Berlin is like it's one of
the grungy cities that I've ever been to
but it's also like super clean if that
make any sense no like like like a
paradox well it's like all the buildings
are mismatched like there's there's no
real cookie cutter anything about Berlin
uh-huh we're like a Munich it's it's
like you're you don't know if you should
like walk on the streets or not like
everything so fancy German engineering
right exactly exactly so like all the
buildings are mismatches a ton of spray
paint everywhere but it's done well it's
not like
you know the lame picture of like you
know cartoon boobs that's like it's like
like actual like people take their
spray-painting seriously over there it's
an art yeah it really is man oh and like
I said les you own the building then you
don't feel like it's art ray comes along
and paints a mural there we got some
Banksy's over there I'm sure there are
some I didn't I didn't have time to
really but it took me two days together
with the jet lag jet lag is I hate it
man
the struggle is real struggle is real no
dude it's like I always try to do mind
over body mm-hmm so like I will stay
I'll try to do body over mine they have
I'll stay up on the plane right over
there yeah and stay up all the way until
like nine ten o'clock and then go to
sleep and like try to get over the jet
lag that way yeah and like doesn't work
it yeah I mean it works better than I
remember well the first time I ever
experiences when we went to London oh my
goodness I was great though for me do
you remember we were stand at this
Airbnb and we this is on tour October of
2014 is it that's the time in London
you're talking about yeah okay yeah that
was the worst that's when I like fell
asleep as soon as like I slept on the
plane fell asleep as soon as we got
there I forget what time it was but it
screwed me up it helped me because
forever reads by I had gone over 24
hours without sleeping because I did try
to stayed up on the plane and all that
and then it was really hard to get to
our Airbnb for some reason yeah and we
had all kinds of issues with the rental
car and we were driving on the wrong
side of the road I was a stick shift
anyway um you know we got this Airbnb
and it was like 2:00 p.m. I'm like I'm
just gonna take a midday nap I woke up
at 11 a.m. the next day
oh yeah see if I could do that man maybe
that would help it was so good rally was
bad too though I don't like to remember
that it wasn't that bad for me going to
Melbourne ever Brisbane is where we
fluency yeah we start in Brisbane e-way
and he'll by the way we've got some good
news on Australia so since we're already
on right here right now our book
minimalism live a meaningful life which
was our first book that came out in the
States and has been translated to close
to a dozen languages now it's not
insulated to Australian wait a minute
no it came out in Australia because you
know they don't they don't have Amazon
over there and so they wash it
approached us they're one of the biggest
publishers in the world and usually we
do everything independently but it's
really difficult to to publish something
independently in Australia so they reach
out to us and one the team up and the
great news is our book it was number two
for two weeks in a row as still is
number number two from last time I heard
in all of Australia and Nan sections
unbelievable man and so mark Manson's
book is still number one which I mean
it's a runaway bestseller but it's been
number two for several weeks there and
so I just want to say thanks to all the
folks in Australia who picked up
minimalism
picked up the hard copy of that and all
of your your local book stores or
airport or wherever you're finding it
and because it's doing so well in the
coming weeks we want you to stay tuned
we're going to be announcing some tour
stops in Australia in New Zealand and
New Zealand in New Zealand man I can't
wait yeah it's going to be great so
we're going to do at least four tour
stops over in your neck of the woods if
you're on our email list over at the
minimalists comm you'll be the first to
hear about new tour stops before anyone
else also our patreon supporters get an
email before anyone else as well because
they get first access to to any of the
tickets before they actually go live to
to the general public and so that's over
patreon.com slash the minimalists but
thank you so much Australia New Zealand
also it's available in Singapore that
whole the whole area over there ha shet
is doing a great job getting getting the
word out and we're going to be visiting
your neck of the woods early 2018 stay
tuned more details on that so anyway
you're over in enjoying Becca Germany no
it was great man anyone jet-lagged but
yes I finally got over it and then when
I got over it I was like okay I'm going
to do this meet up in Berlin I you know
on the podcast I said I would definitely
do something in Berlin
so I sent a tweet out the day before the
event like noon yeah sent it out that
night another tweet just a reminder and
then I think maybe a third tweet the
next day just from your personal account
yeah and I did this on Instagram as well
and I was shocked man like 10 15 people
showed up I mean just from a few tweets
in Neverland that was it was kind of
cool and you know Josh like our audience
or like the kindest people man I know it
is unlike I am I feel so good like when
we are you know in anywhere any city in
a venue and everyone gets up to leave
and like there's not trash everywhere
yeah like it's usually pretty clean yeah
and it'll be a few exceptions but yeah
just the people that were dragged to the
event right through these minimal it got
blown popcorn on the floor
it just blows my mind man like how how
awesome our audiences man um so anyway
like 10 15 people showed up got some
really cool perspectives just from you
know people living in different places
in Germany but also like there's a gal
from Poland there there was a guy from
Denver there who married a gal from I
forget what country I'm like they ended
up in Berlin they just had a baby but
yeah it was really really cool and then
the coffee shop owner
I think it's called Nano coffee as where
I was um so if you're in Berlin and you
haven't tried nano coffee it's freaking
delicious um but the owner there man he
was so nice like I went there and just
started talking to him about how awesome
his coffee shop was and how I
appreciated the very short menu that he
had and he already rated yeah and he was
telling me he was like man it was really
hard for me to get business at first
because people would come in and they'd
want to like your caramel macchiato
right and I was like did you tell him to
go to Starbucks and he laughed and he's
like no I didn't tell me that he's like
but you know people were upset we didn't
have a flavored drink sure we've been
trained one particular way is because of
marketing and branding is very effective
yeah these advertisements are very
effective to increase our desire for
something we didn't even know we desire
have you
had a caramel macchiato of course yeah
they are so fat bastard they are so good
though I think it is all the sugar are
you right right well it's a it's a giant
milkshake this heated with a little
coffee of it yeah yeah it's not a cold
milk shake so I was explaining to him I
was like do we have a coffee shop in st.
Petersburg Florida right and I was like
we try to keep the menu pretty simple
down there I was like what we get the
same exact thing and then you know
someone leaves us a crappy one-star
review they didn't have caramel
macchiatos it's alright well we have
compensated for that we do this bourbon
vanilla yeah syrup that is that is done
in-house sarah makes it whoo she's one
of the owners of the coffee shop and and
it's done with intention and it's sort
of kept behind the counter and we offer
it to people who want that as an
alternative yes but we what we try to do
is educate people on and man it's
difficult when people are trained to do
something one way and they're trained to
expect one thing that re-education
process is to show them hey that's that
is a way but there is not only a
different way but a better way to do it
and I think in a way that's kind of what
we do with with minimalism we're not
saying you can't yeah I think the
standard American Dream of the big house
and and the picket fence or the
three-car garage the four extra bedroom
then one point six kids right right like
that's the caramel macchiato of of
living right right that's one way to do
it but but there might be a better way
to do it then following the same exact
template that you've been told no many
of those ingredients might work
I have friends like Eva and Leo who have
six kids and that's great for them it
works really well for them personally I
choose not to have six kids right and so
I think I think it's important to
realize that you can have you know a
little bit of simple syrup or you can
have your coffee black as well you know
my life it tends to be more of a black
coffee kind of life get down to the
essence of it decocked life down to it
it's most essential part so you can
really enjoy the flavor of the thing but
you can also add you can you can add
things deliberate
and still make it a delicious drink or
delicious life yeah right and so
speaking of the coffee shop but one of
the co-owners Joshua Weaver who does a
lot of photography for us
he was just in town this past week we
were here in Missoula where it is it
looks post-apocalyptic right now I mean
so bad I woke up this morning I was like
still smells like campfire
it smells like my house is on fire yeah
and so for those of you unfamiliar this
time of year usually later than now it's
usually like September a forest fire
star you know lightning hit somewhere it
gets kind of dry and and we have to
start continuing with forest fires well
the worst fires in the country right now
are in western Montana which is where we
are specifically around Missoula there's
something like 13 fires five of which
around Missoula in every direction okay
so it looks like a really bad 2010
Instagram filter everywhere you go in
fact we used to have mountains here and
now it looks like there is a mirage of
mountain oh my god typical bidam
disappears as and so half the state is
on fire and we're it makes it hard to
like debris yeah man like yet so I
apologize in advance if I'm coughing or
if my voice sounds a little yeah a
little little
what is next to raspy I don't know where
I'm looking for but yeah it's because of
the smoke it is it is it does make it a
little crazy so it's funny I don't know
what I'd rather have man like what well
because I was just thinking no matter
where you live you're gonna have to put
up with something yeah like if it's
Southern California yeah yeah right but
even there like the joke is like the
state bird is you know big airplane with
water coming out right all right I mean
they stuck to those four slides over
there but yeah I don't know why I'd
rather deal with like a lot of rain
once when it's dry and not on fire it's
great out here right the problem is it
gets dried and catches fire real easy
yeah I mean it's it's really bad for us
right now I I don't spend time outside
like I'd like to right now bro I mean
we'd even did the photo
so Joshua Weaver came out we're doing
some photos for the podcast to help
promote the podcast but also to promote
the second half of this lessons now Tori
and get some images so we can we can
share that online and he came out here
and really we can't even do like the
beautiful outdoor shot because hey we
can't stay outside very long right now
and be like you don't get that same
beauty when the mountains are missing
from from the landscape and so he came
out and then yesterday we had Jake the
producer from Nightline come out and
note he's he's going to be joining us in
Brooklyn and Manhattan most likely when
we're out there in September we got some
news on that as well so our Brooklyn
stopped sold out our Manhattan stop
there's probably like literally a
handful of tickets like five or six
tickets left in in Manhattan right now
it was actually sold out but we released
some of the the count tickets we had to
take over it's just blows my mind like
how far we've come at keys remember the
first time we were in New York yeah we
had our first tour stop in New York City
was in Queens oh my how many people
showed up like 25 people maybe maybe me
and that was our biggest tour stop right
I mean it was unbelievable I'm never
selling out to Brooklyn shows yes we
have a third one so we have a third New
York show we just added one we have 22
dates I believe 22 dates we're going to
be throughout the United States and
Canada we're actually starting in Canada
at the end of in the valgus let me pull
this up real quick go to lessons now
calm for all the information but we're
starting a Toronto that's sold out and
we just got a way bigger theater that
one is close to selling out Ottawa
Montreal we're going to be in both of
those cities I think those will sell out
they're still maybe a hundred or so
tickets left in both cities Vancouver as
well so we're hitting the west coast of
Calgary and Edmonton we have some of
them we've done more tour stuff in
Calgary and Edmonton than just about
anywhere else be clearly yeah that's
like right there yeah it's just north of
where we are and Edmonton by the time
this comes out might be sold out there
might be a few a few tickets left
Calgary there's less than 20 tickets
left in Calgary and then after Canada
after the six stops in Canada we're
headed over
to New York City we've got three stops
there Brooklyn Manhattan and then
Brooklyn that second Brooklyn is sold
out that's why we added that first show
on September 20th we also stopped in
Philadelphia in between those so we'll
make the quick jaunt
over to Philadelphia and then we're
hanging out for Nightline as well they
did a house tour they came out here and
did a house tour at Ryan house and they
did a health store at my house within
backs was there she made us all dinner
and it was great man I'm really like
such a good cook oh my god the food was
so a good lesson yeah so all the stuff
she made last night our recipes from
minimal wellness.com ribeye same in some
ella burgers Ellie used to get so mad
because I would call Ella I would call
elk steaks so you can get elk out here
you know they're easily hunters who will
trade you something for elk meat right
and so we had Ella burgers les burgers
and I used to call them Ella burger
she'd get so mad but then then she just
says she came to terms it's some other
girl named Ella that were really fine
with that
yeah did she when I was like Oh have an
elevator she's like oh y'all have an
elevator - that's a different Ella
her her Twitter keeps getting funnier
and funnier it's at Ellis and which by
the way Charlie makes money Newport
chocolate if that was the one the other
day all this chocolate makes me want to
eat more chocolate she's adorable yeah
just this our last night we were after
you left we were playing bucking Broncos
why we just got in the grass in the
backyard and like we're pretending to be
the buck because of the fairs going on
right now Missoula saw her we're playing
bucking Broncos with her and she's like
I will never ever fall off a bucking
bronco so haha show continued no it's
just really the way we catalog her child
is not a scrapbook it's just one Pippi
140 characters at a time I'll never fall
over Brooke a booking brung ya at Ellis
and we take her to the fair she's going
tonight actually oh cool yeah yeah so
you see like crazy Fair accident in Ohio
I heard like several people either got
injured or died yeah it was it was
terrible but but it's like watching that
I'm like
and I don't want to write any more fair
rides no III wouldn't like it well on
those rides but she's going tonight
because of the bucking Broncos are
tonight you know that reminds me I got
told her audience yet but I went
skydiving
holy moly you did yeah man that was a
like the beginning of July you're trying
to convince me to do it but my term life
insurance is lapsed I'm trying to go get
a new policy this year and I can't
afford to go skydiving
anyway anyway it was it was awesome in
I'll talk I'll talk more about that
later well I don't mean I don't mean do
know we're in the middle we're in the
middle east toward eight so we can pause
them and talk about skydiving man no it
was you and Mariah went right yeah so my
buddy
uh Brian who I've known him as long as
I've known you
his brother was my dad's business
partner growing up he came out with his
one out to sea on say he proposed
through when when when they were out
here that was kind of cool but anyway we
were up in Whitefish yeah checking out
glacier and we're trying to figure at
this hotel and we're trying to figure
out what we're going to do the next day
right so we were thinking about like you
know maybe whitewater rafting or
ziplining right and then the ask you
this vote is going finding more
dangerous than skydiving it feels to me
like you win I don't I don't have to
look up the statistics it doesn't feel
more dangerous skydiving feels more
dangerous for sure
I'm sure it feels more dangerous I'm
just like I know driving a car is way
more dangerous than an airplane flying
in an airplane driving a car is more
dangerous than skydiving I mean I mean
statistically more Dru
yeah more deaths happen in car capital
yeah per capita than skylight yeah I'd
have to I mean I'd have to look up the
data but I heard that one time that's
shocking to me but I believe you but uh
yeah I mean I might be wrong on that if
I am then tweet me at Ryan Nicodemus and
make fun of me for being wrong anyway um
so the the concierge am I saying that
right yeah she was like call me
and co-chairs yeah first he was like oh
I also just got the skydiving pamphlet
someone just dropped him off yesterday
and Brian's eyes got really really big
like this is the opening scene to a
horror film yeah man let's go skydiving
and I'm like I thought Mariah was not
going to do it right so I'm like okay I
was like I got a casa da she was smarter
than that too I was like I gotta talk to
variety I was like but if she's down I
was like I'd be down so we go back to
the hotel the hotel room and the girls
are in there and were like so what do
you think about skydiving and I'm
totally expecting Mariah to be like no
why don't we go whitewater rafters so
like she was my total scapegoat yeah and
she was like we go look at butterfly
right and she's like okay I'm like what
but maybe no you're supposed to say no
and what you know what then when she
said yes though like I really wanted to
support that because ever since we've
been in an accident
January 2014 where you almost died the
Carla's over yes before we went out on
tour yeah she's got some like she's had
some like just problems with being
nervous when it comes to I'm trying to
think like what we've done that she was
really nervous about um like hiking
mountain biking like now you know like
if we go mountain biking you know I'm
like barreling down the hill right and
she's like really taking her time with
it yeah um there are a couple other
things where she just little hesitant if
we're out on the water
um we had a jet ski was like our
neighbors that the the cabin we were at
it was like a friend of a friend's cabin
they let us use it their neighbors had a
jet ski that they let us borrow yeah and
go on and I was like it was a waverunner
not a jet ski and what's the difference
she was like slow down jet ski lake you
start off with with like laying down and
then eventually stand up and you go
where like with a waverunner you just
sit on it yeah which one the key to
having that much easy yeah neither Oh
Josh I'll hand you a mirror and show you
the key to happiness oh here is the key
to have it yes Drake we need about a
thousand more mirrors in here no um
so long story short like she has been
really really nervous
ever since the car accident yeah so for
her to want to go skydiving I was like
so proud of her yeah I'm like oh wow
like she is I know that she's scared as
hell mm-hmm but she's gonna like face
this fear head-on and she's going to go
skydiving so like I didn't want to talk
her out of it because I thought maybe
this would help her you know kind of
push through that that nervousness that
she's been feeling sure and dude I gotta
say leg everything's everything's okay
until like that door opens I'd like to
stick your legs out and like the wind is
just like you can't keep them together
they're just like flailing everywhere
yeah and you're like okay I guess I'm
gonna I'm going to jump out of this
plate and then like and it was tandem so
you're you know we're attached to an
instructor and then like they push you
out dude there is not there's no words
to describe him in the freefall is just
well first off this was the best view I
have ever seen in Glacier National Park
I can only imagine like that that was in
its on its own was like just amazing
like skydiving in Glacier freaking crazy
it's hard to appreciate a drennan one
though um I did the best I could are to
like look around because I knew that was
going to happen and even like the
instructor his wife she's one that like
you know check seein and like does all
the paperwork and stuff both of them are
like it's going to go so fast like you
know try to take it in make sure you
look around so forth and so on yeah um
so yeah I did I did my best like to look
around I tell you the coolest thing I
saw
so there's um Lake McDonald in Glacier
National Park right and you could see it
over over the mountain yeah and like as
I'm looking and I'm like oh there's like
McDonald there's like McDonald isn't
like it just disappeared you know like
the as we fell all right
that was pretty cool but uh yeah the
adrenaline is nuts um it gets to a point
though man where you're you're free
falling and like you hit that terminal
velocity and it feels natural to like
it's really strange
you know it's terrifying what it's
called terminal velocity but dude it
feels like I was like oh wow like feel
like a bird and then like you're so high
up you can't there's no perspective on
really how fast you're falling right so
it's it really really was like a really
pleasurable experience and then when we
landed um yeah my head was like a
buzzing dude it was so like now I know
where the term buzzing comes from like
my head was literally yeah like I was
literally buzzed five vibrating digits
crazy um but yeah it was a lot smoother
than I thought so I thought like when
the shoot came out it'd be like this
really you know crazy like whiplash jerk
not at all man it was really smooth the
whole the whole process was smooth it
was a skydive Whitefish if you're gonna
skydive only one time in your life yeah
I would recommend coming out to Montana
and doing it in Glacier it was I can't
imagine a better place to skydive and it
was like a perfectly clear day it was
beautiful man huh
well well speaking of skydiving we're
skydiving in the Salt Lake City did for
a scenic we did a nice transition best
friend where we're going was well
skydiving in the mountain we're gonna
for eclis skydiving into the Mountain
States we'll be in Salt Lake City plenty
of tickets left in Salt Lake
surprisingly usually on the last several
tours have been on Salt Lake City has
sold out first almost every time but
we've got plenty of tickets left there
come on out Salt Lake City Denver run
that they are almost sold out and in
Phoenix we're gonna have a special guest
in Phoenix our friend Joshua Becker is
going to be over in Phoenix with us from
the ocean coming minimalist and then
from there we're headed down to Texas
Austin Texas I think Austin is sold out
it's not there might be like I don't
three or four tickets left Dallas and
Houston after that it's going to be
awesome
then we're going to be in Nashville
Tennessee after that I'm really looking
forward to Nashville man Griffin house
is going to be there he's gonna
open up the show looking overboard our
buddy Adam lives there yeah he's gonna
take some pictures for us um what else
buddy Austin Hartley Leonard lives there
hopefully he's going to come out oh did
he move yeah he moved out there I'm here
so no he did hit a second kid he's also
very talented know what else is a breach
the parlor right
yeah just called barista yeah barista
parlor no it's brief de parler you're
right as a barista parlor yeah you're
right
coffee shop the good coffee shop so
we'll be in Nashville and then from
there washington DC atlanta and tampa as
a linux without yet
I know Atlanta has not been shocked
there well there so it's a big theater
and same Washington DC it's a huge
theater our friend Cal Newport is going
to be in DC and in DC and in Atlanta
it's going to be JP see you I cannot
wait it's gonna be so much so my god
it's gonna be awesome or it's going to
be a disaster you know enjoy no we both
know it's going to be it's going to be
an awesome disaster yeah J fees here is
great as a really great parody videos
called ultra spiritual so I think he's
going to spend 90 minutes making fun of
us on stage yes and all the ironies of
minimalism and yeah that and then in
Tampa we should ask Seth ban our friend
Seth brought brother Cephas their new EP
just came out called not that important
and it's really good we should ask them
to open up for us yeah they could do
like an acoustic Setters I'm not sure
that him and his brother they're not
really an acoustic now they do great I
mean I have you heard them play
acoustically I haven't Weaver was saying
they really don't do that awesome really
good yeah be great to have them
yeah I'll reach out to him and ask him
then we're finishing the tour and
December in Detroit and Milwaukee the
two best cities to be in during the
winter time yes exactly so I'm making
sure that I bring my my biggest coat
that I have will be in Detroit in
Milwaukee but I shouldn't say we're
ending the tour then because in the
spring will be headed over to Australia
announcing those dates really soon yes I
just love how like I always I always
think like oh man is probably going to
be our last tour I can we just keep
adding on which is a great thing I love
going on tour don't get me wrong and now
like Mariah doesn't work that she can
come with us to a lot of these places
like it hopes and hopes a lot he's a lot
more fun you know what's really nice
about this we've figured out a good
pattern as well so we don't stay out
touring perpetually we're doing 40
cities this year but we never do more
than four at a time so we'll go out in
three or four cities we call a wave of
cities so for example when we go to the
East Coast we have three stops in New
York and one stop in Philadelphia it's
four cities and then we fly back home
for a couple weeks and then we go out to
Salt Lake City Denver and Phoenix in
those three cities and then we're back
home for three weeks after that I think
and then we go out to Texas for three
cities and then we come back and so we
figure out a way to to make it work so
that we're not on the road perpetually
but still get enough cities in there
that we can we can see a lot of our
audience and maybe next year we'll make
it over to Europe I mean we have a huge
audience in Germany and obviously the
London UK and mission other places we
should look into that Tokyo would be
awesome to do stop there yeah yeah and
the rest of Europe no you just got me
thinking we could go in like a world
tour next year anyway yeah so stay tuned
to that you can find all the tickets
cities dates theaters all that fun stuff
at less is now calm what else we have
going on
I mentioned the the Nightline thing we
did the house tour Oh real quick about
Germany okay so yeah so Berlin was great
so the the meetup was great coffee shop
was great the owner was awesome and then
and then Mariah and I took a train to
Munich didn't get off at the right stop
oh no ended up making our Train read
like an extra three hours long it was
fine that was just we're just dumb
Americans uhm but yeah the train ride a
novelty it was beautiful really enjoyed
it but it's cheaper to flying it's
faster yeah I just took a train because
we had the time and I've never taken a
train in Europe before it was worth it
like for the one time experience yeah
uhm but yeah we got to Munich and then
that my 15 year old self would have been
bored as hell man and Munich because it
was my grandmother my aunt my uncle
Mariah and I
oh and also my step gram
father so my Oman oppa for all intents
and purposes um
the six of us going around and myoma
showing me her friends uh all of them
like owned all of her friends that she
was introducing us to own these gust
houses which are basically ends ah it's
like we have a few rooms to sleep in
they always have beer and maybe some
food maybe like like a most of them
don't be in the kind of yeah like most
of them didn't have food okay um but
yeah it was just like watching my grant
my my grandma my OMA talk German to all
her friends and but like so my 50 year
old self I would've been like oh my god
like is this is what we're going to do
today but my 35 year older we locate
bored and right exactly like my 35 year
old self it was so awesome to like see
her reminiscing with her friends and
just knowing that like this is probably
the last time um she'll make it over
yeah that she's gonna go to Germany yeah
she's in her eighties yeah and yeah she
just turned 82 this year in February and
then um you know she showed us like
where her house was where she grew up in
the bomb shelter she used to run into
you know with her in the when the sirens
would go off the school she went to like
where she would walk from school to home
the farm house dude so she worked at
seven years old man she talked this
farmer into hiring her to work on the
farm and she was telling me how like the
pitchfork was twice the size of her and
she's like looking back she's like I
have no idea how I was able to like
manage that yeah but like she had to
step up I mean she her mom like
temporarily gave her up to a foster home
her and her sister because she like hurt
her back or something and couldn't work
right so she can't provide for the kids
so like she had to put them off on the
state to take care of for a few years
and yeah it's just really really crazy
crazy upbringing but like you know this
is actually maybe a good segue to our
topic for this podcast with a nostalgia
bar yeah like it was really awesome like
being there and watching her get
nostalgic um what watching her feel
nostalgic and then that kind of you know
transferring over to me and and me even
getting to never been there but I was
like wow like this is really cool like
meeting we went to the farm that she
worked at like talked to the um I guess
it was the the kids that she grew up
with um it was it was those kids parents
who owned the farm that she worked for
or whatever but but yeah it was great
man um so I'm sorry I did not - all
those in Munich who were hoping I would
do a spontaneous meet up down there
sorry I didn't get to it but we'll get
there yeah next we'll get there next
year but yeah every single day like it
was my it was hanging with my family and
yeah I just wanted to make the most of
that time with my grandma in Germany and
it was it was great we went to Munich
Munich is a beautiful city but yeah um I
definitely got a nostalgic feeling being
there and which is weird because it's a
that's almost like a false analogy
because you've never been there book
yeah it was really strange like what
like her nostalgia was like rubbing off
on me yeah
and so let's let's talk about nostalgia
yeah everyone necessary recently called
nostalgia is dangerous and to me it was
a fairly innocuous sort of speaking to
read that yeah we can actually it might
make sense there in one of the questions
but we can talk about it real quick uh
actually yeah I'll read it but before we
before we do that a couple other things
we'll just finish out the right here
right now a segment I wrote an essay
called keep travel simple so Ryan you
and I are for the first time we were
putting our name on a physical good
which Hippocrates I know right ah no and
it was a hard decision to really do it
so I wrote about why we decided to do
that I've had probably over a thousand
people certainly hundreds of people but
probably over a thousand people at this
point asked about the damn bag that I
carry and the document great documentary
working up by that bag yeah hey where
can i buy something your your
documentary inspired me to buy something
that's how I saw that first but then I
realized like oh wait a minute it is
it's the one item that adds more value
to my life than anything else because of
the amount that we that we travel
salutely and and so it's a great bag and
it's made by a guy named Malcolm von ta
or at least it was made by a guy named
Malcolm Phan ta and he stopped making
bags in 2012 well after the documentary
came out and Ryan you and I we did a vid
called pack like the minimalists it's on
our youtube channel youtube.com slash
the minimalist and we show how we pack
for a 10 month trip when we were on tour
in 2014 and everything that I packed for
a 10 month trip was in this shoulder bag
basically it's a duffle bag that also
functions like a suitcase it's a duffel
bag suitcase it's neither a duffel bag
nor a suitcase and it it's the best bag
of ever used and I've tried other bags
after because this thing I've been using
it for six years now and I've beaten the
hell out of it into hundreds of cities
and I know at some point it's going to
it's going to disintegrate because I've
beaten it so much it's still ticking but
I've looked for other bags as well and
I've never found anything that's come
closed for me now I'm not saying it's
the appropriate bag for everyone else
I've had so many people reach out and
then Malcolm Phan Thiet reached out and
he said hey how about I've had someone
enter if we got a thousand yea inquiries
and he got five hundred or another
thousand inquiry right alright and so
he's had a bunch of people reach out to
him and the thing is it was a very
limited run bag at first he he only made
three hundred ever right it was three
hundred in existence and so when me you
and Colin all had one we were on tour in
2012 like those one percent of the bag
we had one percent of the bags in our
trunk not even knowing that we did in
anyway we decided after a lot of talk
together to partner with him he's
starting a new bag company called packed
bags PA Cady bags and you can find the
essay that I wrote called keep travel
simple and also he's doing a Kickstarter
for these bags to see what the interest
actually is if people are interested in
it at packed bags comm PA K tea bags
calm Shauna can put a link to that in
the show notes as well just a word of
warning you probably don't need a new
bag and we're not trying to push a new
bag on to you that's certainly not our
message but you know what I was going to
say I think like someone who needs to
bag well first of all you don't need a
bag like the bag will help your travel
at some point you need a bag if you
don't have all right yeah of course but
like I think about Mariah right now who
has
a like my old mission workshop bag yeah
and it works yeah but it's miserable for
her right and I love the mission
workshop it's that's not this the
pamphlet we're in right now our mission
we're talking about opening do the
backpack is amazing like it is it's
waterproof I think it's like 40 liters
or holds a ton of stuff and that's part
of the problem right and that's that
it's kind of it but so yeah this is not
a knock on mission workshop they're a
great company but for Mariah that
particular style of bag it's miserable
for like she doesn't like if she's got
to get something out on the plane and
it's at the bottom of the bag yeah just
unpack everything to get to the bus okay
so does she need a new bag no but like I
know that this bag will significantly
help her be less stressed when she is
traveling and that's the thing I like
about it's a it's a very unisex bag I
mean in fact so he's doing three colours
of it this time a black one a like gray
slate one and then the the biggest
request has been for navy blue which was
shocking to me and so I guess he's going
to do a navy blue one as well but what
you're saying I just reminded me of I'll
just read an excerpt from this this keep
travel simple essay because it's exactly
the the the dilemma that mariah is in
right now was the same exact of limo I
was in before I I found the bag that was
appropriate for me and so as a starts
like this when I started traveling more
frequently nearly nearly a decade ago I
quickly realized my overstuffed suitcase
would no longer cut it it was bulky
that's her problem right it was ugly she
doesn't have that problem but I have you
know one of those giant ugly Samsonite
suitcases the Dean was like you know
weird and way too big and it didn't fit
in the overhead bin
she might have that problem some
airplanes have to move that big yes I
agree no it absolutely is like she nine
times out of ten has to gate check it oh
yeah so so I definitely like that and so
it didn't fit in the overhead been worst
of all because my suitcase was so
hulking I felt compelled to fill it with
surplus travel gear so right because you
have such a big bag you like well I
might as well fill it up I will bring
this extra
in case item don't bring the surplus
travel gear I have a list of some of the
things I would I would pack just a Kate
unworn swimming trunks extra tennis
shoes excess shirts and pants and
accoutrements that were never meant to
journey with me packing had become a
chore and that was true man I remember I
remember like having to allocate two or
three hours to aside for packing because
I'm going to bring this ocean I bring
that and not only was my bloated case a
nightmare to dig through it weighed me
down literally so if she over packed and
she has a massive backpack yeah it does
weigh you down yeah the one item that
was supposed to aid my trips actually
got in the way so much so that I
developed an aversion to travel dreading
each trip because of the clutter I had
to lug from airport to airport hotel to
hotel city to city so of course I try to
slough of travel bags none of which met
my needs they were too small or too
large or too awkward and they contained
too many pockets sometimes I'd find a
decent bag and it would have like 73
different hidden pockets inside and I'm
like what is this what is this coin
purse size pocket for and why are there
six of them for as bad never made any
sense and so the the the middle of the
essay says and then my friend Colin
write a full time traveler full time
minimalist traveler visited my home for
a week toting everything he owned in one
intriguing bag the gate the getaway by
Malcolm font II a the bag itself defined
categorization it was a duffle bag a
carry-on bag a messenger bag and a
suitcase all in one and it was also none
of these things and that was sort of the
thing that was true for me like the bag
it was a duffel it was a carry-on as a
messenger bag it was a suitcase it was
all of those but none of those at the
same time it's streamlined design lacked
the superfluous implements sported by
every other bag I tried leaving only the
crucial elements for travel a bag that
looked like a casual duffel but
functioned like a suitcase and that was
where the most important thing for me is
it was the size of a of a duffel bag but
it carried what a suitcase would
typically carry
and then I'll read this last paragraph
here and before you can read the rest of
it it's a much longer essay since I
purchased the Malcolm font a getaway six
years ago I traveled to literally
hundreds of cities around the world from
Portland Maine to Portland Oregon
Birmingham Alabama to Birmingham United
Kingdom Hollywood Florida to Hollywood
California and has continued to serve me
as the soul bag I need for all of my
travels best of all this bag worked just
as well for my weekend trips as it did
for my friends year-long globe-trotting
it forced me to pack only the essentials
and this was the important part Ryan it
forced me to pack only the essentials
but without sacrificing the necessities
there was room for everything I needed
from my trips and nothing extra for me
it was the important bag and that's the
important part to know here it doesn't
allow you it doesn't allow room for the
the surplus travel goods yeah and it for
me it was the ideal bag and so the last
paragraph at the very end paragraph of
the s/m will skip forward here it says
this and this is what I want everyone to
keep in mind if you're considering
buying this bag truth be told there's a
good chance you don't need a new travel
bag if you don't please don't feel
compelled to purchase one but if you do
this is the best bag that I have ever
used that's why it's the first and only
physical good that bears our name and
that that's that's what I want want to
get across here if you're interested in
it you can find that whole essay at I
got it two bags calm I got to tell you
dude the putting our name behind this
bag feels much better than like putting
our name on a t-shirt great selling
t-shirts yeah yeah for like coffee I
mean that would be our merch yeah any
any type of March yeah no I I totally
agree on a percent man it's I feel
really good about this and at the end of
the day like if someone out there if you
got to put it on your credit card like
don't buy it
yeah if you don't have you know I don't
know how much the bag is going to be but
if you don't have the money to buy the
bag I assure you your life is going to
be much better without putting that debt
on your credit card yeah and you're
still going to be able to travel fine
and we always say if you if you if you
had to puts on a credit card you can't
actually afford three
and yeah I think that's important
whether it's one of our books or
anything else you can budget for it or
whatever or one of our books you can go
local library and get it for free right
or if you come to one of our events
we'll give you a free book yeah if you
can afford to buy one we're happy to
give you a book for free with this bag
there I know Malcolm is doing a
Kickstarter campaign forward to really
see what the interest is whether or not
it will be available beyond the
Kickstarter campaign we're not really
sure and so that will be the one
opportunity to get the bag is something
you're interested in but please don't
feel compelled to to do so a couple
other things before we move on I'm
teaching a my last writing workshop of
the year it's October 22nd it's a
two-hour writing workshops you want to
learn how to write better the the
workshop is called how to write better
and you can find all the details to that
at how to write better dot-org it's a
distilled version of my four-week class
that I teach so I teach a four-week
class called how to write better and
you're able to take that at any time
throughout the year it's something that
I teach and it's automated throughout
the year but I also do a much less
expensive a two-hour one-day workshop I
say one day because sometimes it goes
beyond the two hours I try not to waste
your time obviously but I want to make
sure you get as much value as you
possibly can so if you're looking to
improve your writing skills your
blogging skills your email or business
emails you want to write that first book
that you've been working on I take
everything I've learned over my writing
career and distill it down to this
workshop and try to point you in the
right direction it's broken up into four
different segments everything from
writing to editing to publishing and and
everything in between so I hope you find
value in that how to write better
dot-org last thing I have here I have
two last things all right which it
sounds like um I was with I was at a
friend's birthday party yesterday and
he's got a five year old
yeah and she's like you know give me
give me one last hug yeah and then give
me another last hug anyways what
you two less things oh well we just at
the end of our podcast and we do the
lightning round we have minimal Maxim's
we just launched minimal Maxim's calm
and we can thank Jess she curates all of
our minimal Maxim's you could find
hundreds of our minimal Maxim's there is
going to minimal Maxim's comm and it
populates a new one each time you
refresh it and you can share them from
there so if you enjoy the the short
pithy hundred and forty character
answers that we give you can find a
bunch of inspirational quote do we so
minimal Maxim calendars haha we could
sell four hundred different t-shirts
with our different minimal master ball
collect all four hundred shun write this
down we're selling out ladies and
gentlemen yeah but it's all free minimal
Maxim's com you can find out the
selection of all of our minimal maxes
and continue to grow thanks to jess who
runs our she's a social media manager
she is great and do another yeah yes
indeed and so you can actually find her
on Twitter as well if you go to the
bottom of minimal Maxim's dot-com the
last thing I have Ryan is patreon so we
refuse to clutter our podcast with
advertisements and so if you want to
help support the podcast we're also
going to start doing a video version of
the podcast we need your help we're
building a podcast studio and film
studio so we can do things like improve
audio quality we can take live callers
on the air we can do video version of
the podcast we can do video SaaS
interviews and in all kinds of
interesting stuff but we need your help
for that none of the money goes to me or
Ryan a hundred percent of the money from
our patreon account goes to building the
podcast studio so we can continue to
make compelling meaningful creations for
you if you want to support the podcast
we'd really appreciate it head on over
to patreon comm slash the minimalists or
you can go to the minimalists com click
on the donate button there at the top
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes but also you get a bunch of stuff
that no one else gets not stuff stuff
but but but creations that we've created
so we're doing these quarterly live
streams we're going to be doing more of
those more than quarterly once we once
we get to our first objective a few
thousand patrons I got
say that livestream we did the other day
yeah for for patrons yeah dude that
because it's such a small group yeah
somewhat I mean there's only there's
less than a thousand of them right it's
it's like it's it feels really intimate
in like I just feel like I can let a
little bit more loose on those yeah it
was a lot of fun so what we're doing is
we're doing these live streams we're
turning those podcast Shawn is editing
them down in the podcast as well and
doing patreon exclusive podcasts we're
going to do more and more of those and
who knows over time we may get down to
doing that even weekly where we're doing
a special podcast just for our patreon
supporters as we get more patreon
supporters out there but I agree with
you it feels like we're in a room
together with with these people it's a
virtual room we're doing this live
stream we're talking to people and you
get we're doing these sessions called
ask the minimalists anything exclusively
for our patreon supporters and it's a
lot of fun yeah I do feel like we can
really open up so you can actually get
access to the the ones we've already
recorded we did a test livestream while
Ryan was in Germany my partner Rebecca
and I know many of you have been asking
when you get to bring your partners onto
the show I think maybe patreon is a
great great way to do that where we
bring back and and Mariah in here and
and have a lot of folks so we just did
this test livestream and people started
asking questions so we had a bunch of
questions so Bex and I well Ryan was
gone we answered a bunch of questions
and that that private podcast is also up
on our patreon page so head on over to
patreon comm slash the minimalists if
you want to check out those the recorded
live streams that are already out there
the private podcast and any of the other
patreon exclusive stuff that we're going
to be creating for our patrons alright
Ron I think maybe we should start the
podcast now we have to point out later I
got some voicemails here
our first voicemail is from Susan what
city is she in she is in Philadelphia
Philadelphia my question is about
sentimental objects to try to make a
long story short I met my husband in a
bar in Georgia when I was 21 I was
living in Manhattan I was just done with
visiting a friend
and we really hit it off obviously I
went back to Manhattan we were trying to
plan he come visit me but he was in the
army and he got sent to Iraq and he said
will you write me letters and of course
I did and the whole time he was there in
the invasion we wrote letters back and
forth and I remember walking to my
apartment building and how excited I
would get just you know open up my
mailbox and see a letter from him
and we really fell in love to those
letters even married for ten years we
have three year old twin boys and I just
know that those letters are sentimental
object I will never be able to get rid
of like scanning them just doesn't tell
the whole story of having been from you
know Iraq and Manhattan and back but I
also know this opens us up to like the
rabbit hole of wanting to keep you know
that the baby closed my son's came in
you know came home and the goal was the
NICU and he was so tiny and he's
strapping healthy boy and like I have
that in my dresser drawer because he
came home in and then of course it opens
up keno letters other people and
starting to feel guilty and I guess my
question is um do you make room for
sentimental objects that matter a great
deal and if so how do you kind of stop
the flood of letting that permeate
everything else in your house that you
attached how you do so Ryan do you make
room for for sentimental item man I mean
I have sentimental items um I tried to
avoid holding on a sentimental items as
much as possible um God she's already
kind of went down the rabbit hole with
the letters yeah so now she's like I
think her question really is is like
okay I've got these letters
I'm not asking how I get rid of these
letters I'm not willing to get rid of
these letters I had a lot of value to my
life which is great and then she's
asking well now that we've got a kid and
I know that I'm gonna want to hang on to
stuff like how do I keep it from from
overflowing so you know I guess the
first question if I was Susan I would
ask myself you know how much room do I
have for these things yeah what's the
real calls right loaning these things be
great that there's no clothes right now
of
of the the baby clothes are already paid
for right so there's nice but there's no
monetary cost or for purchasing those
things at this point that's a phone call
right but there are other costs involved
with that yeah your the cost of the of
space yeah
the cost of time it takes to organize
these things to take care of these
things the the cost of well maybe if it
does get out of hand the cost of new
storage space so that could turn into a
monetary cost Italy it's quite often we
mean I have a friend back in Cincinnati
we used to work with and I remember he
and his family like they bought a bigger
house just because they didn't have
enough space for their stuff and and
they were like really stressed that as
opposed to letting go of the stuff that
they were able to justify having a
larger mortgage being tied to more debt
just because they needed more space for
the stuff which by the way he even
acknowledged to me because I don't use
most of this but I just feel like we
have to hang on to it and and we just
need more space and I'm okay with I'm
not telling and everyone they should
live in a tiny house course not we don't
live in tiny houses in fact well the guy
from Nightline who was out at our at our
houses yesterday you know our house is
maybe 1,200 square feet Beck's and I and
it seems a lot more open than that but
it's fun but it's not a tiny house by
any stretch but it's what's appropriate
for us and we don't have excess storage
or anything I mean we've got plenty of
extra space that we don't fill up but I
don't feel compelled to fill every
corner is really the point right and so
she used the word Ryan that that I tried
to avoid with my stuff she said it has
so much meaning or the meaning we
attached to it and and I think that's an
important she's actually admitting that
like the things have only as much
meaning as you give them write her
letters that were written
I understand they mean something to her
and I'm not judging that at all no but
they literally mean nothing to me but
they could mean something to me if you
love if I allowed them to yeah
and so yeah the thing I always think
about is when something is too precious
I try to let it go
and be just because when something
becomes so precious I become attached to
it in an unhealthy way and so the thing
that I would ask is why am I giving so
much meaning to these things because the
things themselves whether it's the
letter or the baby clothes or whatever
those things don't necessarily have
intrinsic meaning they have only the
meaning we've placed on it and that's
not in and of itself unhealthy what it
is it gets unhealthy when we give it too
much meaning too much significance too
much importance I couldn't live without
blank right my life would be terrible
without blank because the truth is no it
wouldn't break everything would be ok
without those then the question that
becomes how do these improve my life how
do they autumn it my experience of life
and maybe just maybe there's something
she could do with these sentimental
items that enhance her life as opposed
to it because right now that you talked
about having these additional calls the
biggest additional call she's
experiencing right now is the weight
they have on her mind yeah they're
occupying the real space the space in
her mind she's worrying about these
things
she is obsessing over these things
enough to call into a couple of random
guys from Dayton Ohio that she doesn't
know so that so that we can try to help
her with it so it's it's become enough
of an issue that she's worrying and it's
occupying space in her brain so how does
one find the balance between holding on
to everything and incinerating
everything so where's that where's the
balance between that and that that's a
good question because it doesn't and
that's gonna be different for everyone
too right
yeah and often we think it's binary
right like I have to either hold on to
it or I have to incinerate it right and
the truth is well maybe there's
something else you can do with it with
those letters could you turn into a
really great art project yeah really
cool collage or yeah or a huge frame
that you have in your bedroom that is
filled with your your favorite selection
of these letters and by the way I do
recommend even if you're not going to
just scan them I do recommend scanning
them because you're going to it's going
to it's going to
occupy less space in your mind because
you're not worrying about losing those
letters anymore if you you and I Ryan we
did a scanning party people we won't
rehash the whole thing you see the
scanner we use and exactly what we do
with all our photos and stuff the
minimalist comm slash scanning will put
a link to that in the show notes as well
but have a scanning party and go through
those letters together and to find the
ones that evoke the most meaning and
emotion when you're going through them
and maybe you can turn in some sort of
art project whether you said it's a
collage it could be a scrapbook it could
be a digital picture frame that actually
it's a large do they make large digital
picture frames now that are eight and a
half by eleven yeah and you can cycle
through those letters on a digital
picture frame you can set the timer so
every 60 seconds it brings up a new
letter and if they're private letters
you can keep them in a private place
just in your bedroom somewhere and and
you can get more value from it that way
then they're just sitting in a box a
shoebox in an attic or a basement yeah
no I totally agree
III think you know Susan it's I mean
we're not well we are just sharing our
recipes so anything we say it's just
that like it's our experience it's all
right what we would do yeah but Susan
you can you know you feel free to do
whatever you feel is best for you and
your family if I was you I would when it
comes to the baby clothes you know I
would right now put a limit on so for me
if it was myself my limit would be zero
I'm not gonna hang on to baby clothes
now me but I find this with Ella now
when she grows out of something I'd get
rid of it but Susan it's you know if
it's if it's that important to you I
would I would posit that it's not as
important as you think it is but you
know like I said I don't want to sit
here and tell Susan what she should or
shouldn't do if she's looking for some
type of guidelines on how to find that
balance between holding out 2-0 baby
clothes and then holding on to
everything I would say like figure out
what that limit is right now first of
all how much space do you have to store
baby clothes and if you do have space
then limit yourself to just that space I
mean you know holding on to up hair baby
shoes a onesie like if that's what you
want to do great but put those put those
rules into place now so when you do find
yourself with
heap of baby clothes in a trash bag now
you're not just going to take that trash
bag and then put in the closet hold on
to everything like right now decide what
is your limit what do you have a room
for what do you have time for I found
four with Ella it's actually a good it's
a good time for me to teach her as well
because when she grows out of something
she knows that we go donate it and
instead of just saying we have to go
donate this we talk to her about why
she's donating it and when she goes to
the donation warehouse with us sort of
goodwill and and we're donating her old
clothes
she says this is how other kids can wear
because I can't wear it anymore she's
understanding that I didn't understand
that at age four right but she's
understanding that at age four so it
becomes this this teachable moment and
that that we wouldn't get otherwise if
we were just clinging to her to her
style oh that's a great point Suman is
like so Susan what do you want to teach
your kids through this process Oh like
so what lesson do you want them to get
out of this do you want them to you know
realize that memories are inside of us
and we don't have to have a bunch of
physical items to remind us of those
memories or you know do you want the
lesson to be hey it's okay to hoard
whatever you want to Lord and I know
Susan isn't order or turning into order
but but yes I would ask that question to
Susan is like what do you want to teach
your kids through this process Susan I'd
love to give you and your husband a
couple tickets to our Philadelphia event
which is in September Sean if you could
reach out to her and see if she's
interested in that for anyone else who
wants to comments lessons now.com you
can grab your tickets over there our
next question is from Brandi I think no
no no there's this trip from trip Oxford
Mississippi Oxford Mississippi I have a
small personal time capsule it's maybe
the size of two shoeboxes and I've put a
lot of sentimental memorabilia and the
photographs and stuff like that in there
and I was wondering if you guys would
think it was okay because I don't
necessarily look at it a lot I don't get
any
median joy from it but whenever I have a
family one day I would love to be able
to show my kids like oh yeah this is
what your grandmother looked like at
this time and as a college student I
don't really have enough money to like
scan photographs or to scan a Christmas
card for me to be able to read later on
to remember oh this is what my mother's
handwriting look like this is what it uh
her message was to me at this time and I
don't save everything I only say maybe
two cards that I have it there or two
photographs or whatever
I was just wondering with your guys
stops were on like a personal time
capsule you know it's interesting Ryan
when Jake from Nightline was out at our
houses yesterday I have I don't call it
a personal time capsule it's an old hat
box my mom used to have with some
photographs in it now they're all
scanned already yeah but I do have
that's where the physical pictures
physical pictures is right I know right
we're canceling this podcast right now
Sean Poole plug and yeah I've I found
that yeah those those physical photos
having a curated collection of physical
photos yeah I can go through go through
those with Ella and you know she can see
my mom because obviously if should never
get to meet my mom you know my mom died
in 2009 and Ella was born in 2013 and
and so I can have those physical photos
there as well and and he said his time
capsule is about the size of two
shoeboxes that means you have the
self-imposed limitation you can't fit it
once you get to the to once it's full
you don't you don't go get a larger
you're right you're wonder he didn't
wait he was thinking he had to chew
boxes and was thinking about adding a
third shoe box right right and so I find
that that's great you have this the
self-imposed limitations yeah and and
the question is you just said you don't
really get value from it right now but
you might in some hypothetical future
and then you said I can't afford to scan
things as a college student a Italian
man a scanner is one of the best
purchases that I've ever made if you
can't buy one borrow one yes
um but being a college student dude the
first thing I thought was well I know he
has access to a scanner you have a
college student
like I'm sure there is a computer lab
that one can go to and it probably has a
scanner in there that you could scale
like that's what I'll do is I'll scan a
picture or a card and I'll email it to
myself yeah and then file it in like I
use Dropbox or or I'll just keep it on
my in my gmail and file it away
oh here's the other thing you can do you
could buy one and then use it and then
sell it yeah get a two and you'll still
get a good chunk of your money right but
saying you can't scan it because your
college student that is you're just well
you know what with that attitude you can
yeah and and I mean the truth is it
takes up a lot of time to do it but the
scanner that we use in that well here
I'll just read the the photo scanning
essay because it makes it so the
minimalists comm slash scanning it
here's how the essay starts if you're
going to ask for one physical gift this
year for the holidays or your birthday
you may want to consider a good photo
scanner and there's a link to the the
Doxie scanner that we use if you're
anything like me you probably allow the
overstuffed boxes and albums of photos
to go unchecked over the years and now
they're collecting dust in your basement
or calls it or just sitting there unused
waiting for quote one day to come one
day two of the most dangerous words in
the English language I too held onto
heaps of meaningful photos that added
absolutely no value to my life because
they were hidden away and the prospect
of dealing with them seem daunting
overwhelming not worth the hassle so I
let them sit in the Attic that covered
the garage then inspired by Ryan's
packing party I decided to throw a photo
scanning party because if you put the
word party at the end of anything Ryan
will show up well who brings beard first
I found a high quality scanner I could
rapidly feed photo photos and
immediately save to a memory card which
I could then use a few high-res digital
picture frames you can see the digital
picture frames I have there as well so I
could actually display my important
photos plus if anything was going to
happen to my home a flood of fire
robbery all my photos were safe
a vis secured online thus I'll never
have to worry about losing those
memories of course the memories aren't
in our material possessions but I
discovered a well curated photo
collection triggers all the wonderful
memories of yesteryear without all the
physical baggage and so now if anything
happened to those photos Ryan I wouldn't
feel I wouldn't feel your Adam and many
other all save you know it's not a big
deal
and so scanning them and I won't read
the rest of the essay you can find that
at the minimalists comm slash scanning
they can help trigger some of the
memories absolutely but that's really
the thing trip if and by the way you
don't have to settle then just for the
limitations of that shoebox if you scan
whatever you want then you can it's all
searchable you can say Christmas card
2016 room and you have it all there it
doesn't mean you'll ever access it again
but once it's up there in the cloud you
don't have to have access to it unless
you really want it it's like Ryan's
Instagram account you don't have to
access his Instagram account unless you
really want to but it's all there saved
in the cloud and yeah if you want it
right and so speaking of which my
Germany trip is on there is anyone out
there wants to check it out you don't
have to but if you want to access
pictures of my Germany trip you can go
to my Instagram account at Ryan
Nicodemus the last thing the trip asked
is is okay do we absolve him of his sins
well we can't send you your minimal
certificate just yet well no he hasn't
sent us a nine ninety five here's the
truth man it's okay it's totally okay
but anyone out there it's yeah it's only
okay if it's okay for you and guess what
it's probably not okay for you if you're
calling in and asking if it's okay if
you have to ask that question well yeah
probably not okay I would say sometimes
too though like people they feel like
it's okay but for some reason they you
know they think about what would Ryan
and Josh think and what they judge me
for this yeah well you know we don't
judge anyone if anything we relate yeah
I totally identify where you're at we
can have done and I have been there and
you know is if you feel like just like
Josh said if you feel like it's okay
then it's okay
the only time Josh and I will encourage
you to do anything when it comes to
letting go of your material possessions
is if
it's stressing you out like if there's
if you're looking in the mirror and
you're like oh man this is really
stressing me out I'm going to call Josh
and Ryan and put a voicemail question
and to see if I should be stressed out
or not it doesn't matter what Josh and I
think if you're feeling stressed out
then that is a that is your body telling
you that something needs to change if
you feel okay with the tissue boxes
great
then hang on to them yeah Josh and I
just want you all to be happy that's it
yeah we want you to live meaningful
lives and everyone's going to do it a
little bit differently Sean if you could
reach out to Tripp and send him a copy
of our book essential it's 12 chapters
about living an intentional life and a
couple of those chapters have to do with
stuff the first chapter has to do with
with minimalism the second chapter is
about material possessions and then it
goes into these ten other areas of how
to live a more intentional life
everything from the digital clutter and
technology to relationships and
everything in between
no like that you know it's funny speed
up like the time capsule like your
hatbox yeah so I have a a bag it's like
a really small like duffel bag
that my dad gave me what that has a
bunch of my childhood pictures in it
yeah and when Nightline was there
yesterday I got it out and I opened it
up and dude I didn't even I don't know
why I did this maybe just because there
was room for it but I had the it was a
complete photo album just of that trip
to Hawaii that we took in our corporate
days yeah and as I'm like flipping
through this photo of them like why how
do I have a photo album like it was
because we'll just hidden in that bag
you didn't even know you had yeah the
Guv the the girl who went to Hawaii with
me she put it together and like gave it
to me gave it to me as a gift and I just
never removed all the pictures from it
yeah wait I was just funny I was just
later I have like a yeah this photo
album inside this bag of random pictures
and so I when he left I like took out
all the pictures they put the photo up
in the donation box
anyway if hashanah either sent him the
book version the eBook version or
audiobook now that netbooks our longest
audiobook it's like six and a half hours
long so but it's really good ones read
by Justin Moloch who is a talented
narrator and man he did such a good job
with with the audiobook version yeah
essential is amazing so yeah so check
that out if we have an audible download
code that's probably the best way to do
just send him over to audible now I'm
just going to say Tripp keep keep up the
good work and you know for anyone else
out there who's having an issue with you
know their nostalgic items like Susan do
it ripped it and like limit yourself to
a space and stick to that to that limit
all right let's talk to brandy in Las
Vegas one of the items that I'm having a
lot of trouble getting rid of is
yearbooks from high school and
elementary school middle school they're
big they're clunky but I don't use them
I rarely go to them but I'm just having
a lot of trouble giving myself
permission to let those go because
they're kind of their symbols and
nostalgic in a lot of ways and almost
every English or TV show kind of goes
back and it's always nice flipping to
your grandma's to your book and looking
at all those pictures and it's a nice
memory lane but I don't want to hold on
to these so just wondering what your
guys's take is thank you so what'd you
do with all those yearbooks Millie
incinerate them incinerate them today no
you know it's funny man they actually
have websites now where you can go and
check and see if your your books are on
there
oh really yeah so like I can't think of
a specific website oppression look them
up before this but anyway just search
for online yearbooks yeah and you know
you like you'll get the classmates calm
and stuff where you can get in contact
with old high school friends or you know
childhood friends whatever they went to
school with but what they're doing now
is you can actually choose your
elementary school which is your high
school a year and they have your books
that are scanned and uploaded onto the
site I'm not saying that hers are
definitely on there but they might be
but they might be and I would check it
out I have a look for mine because
like I wait I don't really care about
your books personally no I you know I
was showing LA yesterday so I was such a
fat kid and then I lost it's weird man I
was like I I you had this like cycle of
I mean I was really I was morbidly obese
in your high you remember this yeah when
we first met I was the fattest kid in
school uh in in seventh three bullet
yeah a huge mullet and a huge chin and
everything the glamour shot mullet
picture yes yeah so I was showing all of
these pictures she's like you look silly
I did look silly had a mullet and I was
215 pounds when I was 12 years old man
and then I lost a bunch of weight in
high school because of you know I
discovered the opposite sex and you're
like wait a minute wait and so then I
got super skinny in high school but then
right after that I ballooned back up in
my 20s after I got married I was like
screw it like lame this one Kari Josh no
I'm blaming myself I was like well I'm
honestly I didn't know much about health
like I didn't know well I thought you
know French fries were an ideal
vegetable you know and technically
potatoes are a vegetable medley yeah and
they're fried in vegetable oil yeah I'm
serving the vegetables right there
exactly if I eat to bag the fries my
daily allotment I'm like that anyway
yeah so I I had all these pictures of me
like from high school I don't want to
like to remember all that and so so for
me like also my childhood was not a good
time and like from my mom started
drinking when I was like four years old
and it was really downhill by time we
were seven or eight we were on food
stamps and government assistance and and
I remember like our electricity getting
turned off and just it was a terrifying
time to be a kid and so I certainly
don't want to be reminded of that all
the time personally but a lot of people
had really great childhoods and they
want to
for that and these photos are can be
triggers and so what can you do with
those books we you can do a few things
if you if you want to incinerate them
get rid of them and first find a website
that Ryan is mentioning here and and
find if they're catalogued online
somewhere that's one way to do it you
can also you can keep them on your
bookshelves okay if you have a bookshelf
and they're part of your curated
collection that's fine if they're
references for you and you're going to
use them it doesn't sound like that's
the case for you brandy like they're
kind of in the way for you that's why
you're calling in but for other people
listen to this that might be fine just
to hold on to it it's okay to do that
you don't have to get rid of it but if
you do want to get rid of it's in the
way try one dollar scan com the number
one dollar scan com it has no
affiliation with us I never use it
personally but I've had a lot of readers
tell us they have used it they scan
books and so whether it's old text books
you want to scan or books or whatever
your books anything you want to scan and
then they get rid of the book for you so
you don't have to and then you have it
digitally if you can't find it online
already so so that's that's definitely
something you can do now she used some
adjectives there one that she used a
particular was clunky there big clunky
books and that is a sign so how do you
describe these things that are weighing
you down sometimes the adjectives tell
us a whole lot clearly it's not adding
value to her life if it's if she's using
words like it's clunky right it's in the
way if we're talking about the books
that way they aren't they aren't
preventing the value that we think they
might prevent at some they're not adding
the value to our lives they're
preventing us from from you know
pursuing something that does add value
to our lives yeah there's a lot of
perceived value going on here like she
is she's stressing herself out getting
rid of these things because you know
somehow that she's going to throw away
her childhood or lose memories or
something right but she's obviously you
know feeling some stress and pain
holding on to these things definitely
yeah and so how do we get rid of that
pain we need to find a way to get rid of
these Bluff yeah it doesn't mean if you
have to get rid of them altogether you
can get rid of them physically you can
have them scan
and you get on yourself you can do
something that I still have access to
those memory triggers but but not have
the physical good that's clunky and in
the way for you and she used the word
nostalgia which triggered a memory for
me of the essay that I wrote recently
which triggered this whole this whole
podcast discussion here so I'm going to
read this real quick it's called
nostalgia is dangerous and now people
had an adverse reaction to that when I
when I to me it seemed fairly benign to
say nostalgia is dangerous that's like
saying a knife is dangerous right a
knife is dangerous
yeah it doesn't mean that it is only
dangerous and it means that it can be
dangerous if it's if it's employed
inappropriately so let's read this essay
real quick it's a pretty short one you
can find this at the minimalists comm
slash nostalgia when I traveled back to
Dayton Ohio last month on a quick break
from tour I felt revived by waves of
nostalgia as I maneuvered through my
hometown walking the downtown streets
amid powering buildings glimmering in
the Summer Sun driving the outskirts of
town through cornfields so green they
appeared radioactive passing my
childhood home inhaling the memories of
adolescence but there's a problem with
nostalgia it tells only half-truths and
thus the full truth isn't as fragrant as
my wistful remembrance most of those
skyscrapers are abandoned the cornfields
are subsumed by cookie cutter suburbia
and the house that raised me is boarded
up after decades of disrepair nostalgia
is a rose-colored rear view not only
does it falsely represent the past
keeping us clinging to a two-dimensional
version of life that didn't actually
exist it dampens the present and clouds
the future if we want things to quote be
the way they were or if we hope to make
something quote great again then we're
missing out on how good this moment is
and how great the future can be
don't get me wrong I still love my
hometown not for what it used to be but
for what it is right now and for what
the future holds and I think I think
that's an important thing right like
when I think back to my childhood when I
first go when I first was back in Dayton
for those couple days I did feel like oh
yeah this was wavin nostalgia but like I
said in the essay it's kind of this two
dimensional view because my childhood
was actually pretty shitty right and and
you forget about that and it carries
forward only the things that we remember
as good and the problem with that is
there's no real problem with with
remembering the good stuff I want to
remember the good stuff but also
remember it wasn't all good back then
and if we're constantly living in the
past through nostalgia that's that line
that nostalgia is a rose-colored
rearview yeah it changes the past and
forgets that it isn't actually how we
think it is yeah I was going to say -
and the fun way off base just tell me
but I was thinking that you know even if
let's say it was an excellent childhood
and I wanted to remember it like it made
me think of the the folks in high school
who had like this beautiful high school
experience where you know they were you
know prom king or queen or you know all
this or and yeah the victorian star
athletes but those folks after high
school gets so stuck in the past
yeah then like they never really move
forward you don't want the past to be
the peak right exactly exactly so so
even for you know people out there who
had these amazing childhoods that's
great and you do want to remember that
but yeah don't let that be the peak
that's a great way to saying it um yeah
I mean when it comes to these yearbooks
brandy man uh what what is it that you
really want to hold on to because you
don't want to hold on to every single
page of that yearbook is it just the
page that you're on and that some of
your friends are on is it the page you
know in the beginning where
I don't know if you did this with your
year but I did this in elementary school
I don't think ever got a yearbook after
elementary school can either cert paying
for him all right
um but you would bring around your
classmates and they would write like Oh
have a great summer
signed whoever yeah so like maybe you
know maybe that's one of the reasons why
because it has these notes from her
friends sure so like what what parts of
the yearbook really make you feel a
nostalgic and how can you hang on to
just those parts and get rid of the rest
of it it's anyway yeah anything scanning
is a great way to do I think so too
and by the way that also keeps you from
from losing them if you really do want
to hold onto them because it's
inevitable something can happen to them
mm-hmm or she can cut out the pages and
make a you know a collage and like do a
you know a nostalgic make it useful and
international yeah make it art totally
there's there's a lot of ways but uh but
there's obviously something that needs
to change Brandi so however you decide
to make those changes great we support
you Brandi I'm going to give you a copy
of our book everything that remains it's
my favorite thing that we've ever
created it's a memoir about the
five-year transition of me and Ryan
being a student a corporate guys but
then letting go of everything becoming
minimalist and Shana could reach out to
her either give her the book the eBook
version or it's also on audio book on
audible as well if she wants she wants
the audio book version I didn't uh I
didn't send a good way to I was hoping
to use this example in one of these
questions in the lightening round I'm
definitely not gonna be able to plug it
in but I'll say one of the best just
speaking towards nostalgia in general
one of the best ways to avoid hanging on
to a lot of clutter for nostalgic
reasons is to not bring it into your
house yes and I'll tell you when we are
in Germany dude the nostalgia that I
felt through my gram through my OMA to
my grand algebra proxy and this statue
by proxy yeah man that's a terrible band
name that I was very tempted man that
hang on like we went to the souvenir
shop uh-huh I wanted to buy a Stein I
wanted to get the Ben Stein yes
I wanted to buy a Stein I wanted to get
like like a magnet I mean I do haven't
desired to have a magnet I can't even
tell you one but like I saw a magnet I
was like Oh that'd be cool and I'm like
no dude like this is it's great and you
can appreciate this moment yeah I don't
have to have a magnet to remind me of
long suit Germany man in your mentioning
Magnus right now and with the guy from
Nightline Jake he was asking was there
anything you had to compromise on and
join in houses together I'm like I
freaking hate refrigerator magnet hey
hey having magnets on the fridge and
Becks doesn't mind it she didn't have a
bunch when we first met but she probably
had close to a dozen sure and and what
we did is magnets yeah we settled on one
we have one it's a Squatch what yeah
Sasquatch for those of you not in the
Pacific North was no I didn't know
that's how the cool kids were breathing
Sasquatch yeah you know we go looking
for them where we go we go Squatch
hunting Squatch honey but yeah but um
the it's a sasquatch magnet but what we
do is we display LSR work and it's
another lesson for her because any time
she brings home a piece of artwork and
she wants to put it on the fridge she
has a day job has to take down on the
other one because there's only one so
she has to make that decision and she
knows that if that one that she brought
home was going up on the fridge she has
to get rid of the other one she has to
go through the process of letting it go
yeah yeah so like I was did I was faced
with like really Oh like a lot of
impulses to buy souvenirs and I don't
buy souvenirs man and I'll tell ya I so
while we were in LAN suit Germany they
have this parade at this festival once
every four years and it's basically like
the reenactment of one of the princesses
marrying like a Duke or something but
it's like a medieval festival
essentially so if you've ever been to
like the Renaissance Faire in I don't
know what it's Waynesville Ohio if I
died oh yeah like if you've been to
anything like that Josh like it is it's
just like that except
on a much grander scale they do this
huge parade of work and it lasts a month
long yet um but while we were while we
were there you're allowed to like drink
on the streets and stuff but they don't
allow any glass because um it's so many
people like you have to have a cup
essentially yeah so they had these
really really cool copper cups that they
were selling and I bought one it was
like a pint size and then Mariah bought
one it was maybe like a half pint size
and that's what we would put drinks in
and we would um you know during the
festival we could use that to drink out
of when we're at the hotel like I had no
idea I was like oh wow this is really
really handy like I got this
this portable collapsible water bottle
right but it's kind of a pain in the
butt to drink out of all the time
especially like in the middle of the
night if you're reaching for oh hey I do
like it so the cup I mean it actually
was very very functional and it was a
cool copper cup and I was like man I'm
going to hold on to this I'm gonna head
the lot the long suit coat of arms on it
and I got I'm going to bring this home
and I'm gonna like this is going to be
like my first souvenir that you know I
really hold on to becomes a it becomes
more than a souvenir though yeah look at
the time souvenir sort of steeped in and
this meaning that it has virtually no
function right yeah no but it was
functional but you know what my aunt
they were kind of they weren't like
super expensive there they were but
there were enough like it was you know a
couple $20 bills or 20 euro bills like
you got to drop on it and my aunt she
like loved the cup but she didn't spend
the money right like she had you know
her and my uncle odd budgeted for their
trip this was not in the budget
so before I left I was like you know
what like I'm gonna do this exercise and
give my aunt this Cup because I don't
want to open up that can of worms like I
do not want to go down that road even
though I could totally talk myself into
this being functional
me having memories of it and plus Mariah
had hers and I knew Mariah was going to
hold on to hers so I was like you know
what like I mean it wasn't nearly as
cool as mine I don't think so um but
still something there functional and
Mariah she did keepers and we have it
but I gave that to my aunt and like the
joy she got from me giving that to her
like more than the function that you'll
give oh yeah way more man and like I
feel I just feel good that like I'm not
reliant on having a physical item to to
feel that nostalgia yeah like I mean
talking about this trip dude like it and
I'm not looking at any pictures or
anything like just talking about it is
making me feel really warm and fuzzy
yeah so um you know just not bringing
stuff home like that's going to help
that's going to kill 99% of the problems
that people are facing what the static
items is like stop making things
nostalgic or you know don't don't bring
things into your house that you know
you're going to feel nostalgic about
because as soon as it's in your house
it's going to be even harder to get rid
of
yeah the easiest way to let go is not
bring it in in the first place right
absolutely
all right you all we'd love to hear what
you have to say so if you have a comment
or a tip about nostalgia or sentimental
items or anything we've talked about the
day including any advice for any of our
callers today then leave us a voicemail
for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you can also email
a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm we will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode
alright Josh no time it is
welcome izi it is time for our hashtag
ask the minimalist lightning round where
we answer questions from social media we
are on twitter and instagram and
facebook at the minimalists on all three
platforms during the lightning round
this is where Ryan and I do our best to
answer each question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pity answers on
social media if you'd like and you can
also find all of our minimal Maxim's now
at
minimal maxims calm all right our first
question is from Brock eenie martini was
broke a knee broke eenie martini yeah
oh my goodness I look in the next name
did you just mess with me with names on
this okay okay on two so I listen to
it's funny of Chris D'Elia his podcast
called congratulations he he answers
like Twitter questions at the end and
when someone has like a silly Twitter
name like bro kini martini he's like
okay that's what questions from broke
eenie martini change it every time he
gets on this ridiculous change it get a
new Twitter name maybe that's a real
name yeah it's like a tryina Kadima 69
change it yeah all right bro kini
martini wants to know do you think
nostalgia has a purpose is there a
healthy form of nostalgia or is it
inherently useless to hold on to the
past
all right my short answer is here's my
minimal Maxim many things are both
useful and dangerous an automobile is
useful an automobile is dangerous
likewise for nostalgia word spoken true
my short answer is memories exist with
or without a physical item in hand
don't use nostalgia as an excuse to
hoard so good our next question is from
are you sure you're not messing with me
on names your dueña change it I'm just
kidding
that's for actual name I know I'm just
I'm joking it's a very beautiful name
I am just projecting that I cannot
pronounce their name correctly it's like
in Germany uh-huh my Oman Oprah and my
uncle they're staying with my Alma's
friend he's like the master yodeler in
town how do you tell you bout that he
gave us like our own
personal he has a recording studio in
the basement uh-huh you can find them on
on iTunes actually I'll say that for the
recommended section when I commend it
cuz it's dude it is great it's what I
realized about yodeling especially
because it's in German like I can
totally just like zone out and it's like
a pleasant its pleasant music to listen
to and I can but I can't really bless
words I love it dude yeah I don't know
that's just like the the German that I
have in me or maybe it does feel
nostalgic too but anyway um his name was
Richard Rendell and his name's not
Richard though it's like hard like it's
you know like I can't pronounce it the
way that that they pronounce in German
yeah but I found that a lot with um a
lot of German names like the guide the
hotel's name was Stefan but that is not
how he was like just call me Stefan
like the way he was saying it yeah
announce it so you couldn't manipulate
yeah uh no offense to ear dueña I am
just like I said projecting my
insecurities that I can what's her
question
oh yeah she did have a question she said
I would hashtag ask the minimalists how
they interpret the impact of nostalgia
on historical awareness and how
minimalism might change that in the
future well my answer is a line from the
essay that I read about nostalgia is
dangerous and it's just a short live is
my favorite line from that I say
nostalgia is a rose-colored rearview and
if I were to expand on that briefly I
would just say that yet when we look
when we look backward we need to make
sure we're taking full account of the
past so nostalgia is different from
history yeah and make sure you're not
looking backward as you're walking
forward oh my god is that your maximum
what's your answer
my answer is the past shapes are present
but does not ever equal our future yeah
I think I think it's true it's a it
could be a good indicator of the future
but it doesn't equal the future we don't
have to come to the path
when we're planning our future all right
David
change it just kidding David is a lovely
name
David writes in does nostalgia have a
place in today's world well my answer
that sounds like a tautology but I think
it's true everything in today's world
has a place in today's world the
question then is what will we choose to
be nostalgic for in tomorrow's world
you should stop or else I'll stop
snapping into the microphone
um I don't you know ah I mean I agree
with you because you're my best friend
uh-huh um but I think there are some
things in today's world that there are
not places for but I just mean literally
oh yeah everything in today's world
literally has a place in today's world
but but the his question was more about
lay not absolutely look like should it
be here and that's a different question
yeah definitely okay um my answer is
this miss miss perfectly soared over my
short answer is this nostalgia can make
us feel warm and fuzzy when one feels
stressed over the nostalgic items they
hold on to it's time to let go yeah I
mean I think that's important when you
look back and you're like these things
aren't adding any value to my life
whatsoever they're stressing me out but
they're supposed to make me feel good
and they're doing the opposite man that
is a key indicator that I should head
for the hills get rid of this stuff yes
absolutely all right Joe well you know
what it's time for our added value
portion of the show this is where we
each recommend something that has added
value to our lives recently and I've got
a few things I know I'm late to the game
on this but we haven't recorded a
podcast together in studio in a while
Jay Z's new album 444 oh yeah that's
good man it is so it's like it's finally
it's like what I hoped he would do with
his last um
grown up and introspective and it's
critiquing his past life in a way that
it's sort of the opposite of nostalgia
where he's looking back and saying man
here are the things I messed up with you
know and and he's critiquing the sort of
cultural trends when you see people
talking on their money phones on on
Instagram or whatever and he sort of
critiquing the the validity of consumer
culture which he fully acknowledges that
he was a part of and he talks about
investing in the future in different
ways to invest and man I found that it
was like grown-up mature hip-hop that I
had not heard before from certainly from
jay-z it was still jay-z but it was it
was also a beautiful album was first
time he used one producer on the entire
album this is 13th studio album he used
the same producer on every track of of
the album and that added this cohesion
that you wouldn't otherwise experience
it didn't have any like standout hit
singles or anything like that it was an
album that was meant to actually be an
album and I'm an album kind of guy like
I don't like listen to singles I like
listening to a a cohesive body of work
and appreciating that for what it was
and man he did a great job also by the
way he acknowledges you know cheating on
his wife and does a whole song
apologizing and to Beyonce and it's I
thought was really powerful man and it
was almost like a response to her and it
wasn't a cop-out it was it was owning up
to indiscretions and just terrible
behaviors from yesteryear and and not
one in the future to be like the past so
the opposite of nostalgia not wanting he
wanted his future to be better than his
past yeah and and the thing if you take
anything from this episode it's not one
in the future to be like the past it's
why in the future to be better than the
past and aspiring to have a better
future Ryan tryin to get it ready to
start snapping a couple other
recommendations real quick I binge watch
last month a TV show called billions
have you heard of this show billions
yeah billions no like
The Sopranos if Tony Soprano was a Wall
Street guy
we're like the bad guys the good guy of
the show like he becomes the protagonist
even though in real life he's the
antagonist anyway it's called billions
and I binge watched the first two
seasons and their parts of it where the
writing is so like overwrought and I
could make a really good novel but it
doesn't work perfectly in a TV show but
for some reason I loved it because the
lines were the dialogue was so
over-the-top yeah there was something I
loved about these these like little pity
lines you and I would never say to each
other because they were it takes a whole
team of writers to craft a line as
clever as that but there was something I
loved about it in the show and something
I loved about the aesthetics of the show
as well and there was also this dynamic
between the the two main characters one
of the good guys played by Paul Giamatti
and the bad guy is named Axelrod he and
his firm is called axe capital but
anyway there's this dynamic this tension
between the two of them it's really
great and it's a it's a great show an F
I have to recommend to you specifically
Ryan but I will recommend this to anyone
so far I've been using it for over a
month and it's called Robo killer and
they I think it charges a couple bucks a
month to use it but it kills robots oh
my god GB really importantly you do you
have a problem with robots in testing
your home it's really important get the
Robo killer app know what it does is
with the AI stuff on the on the uprise
yeah I'm not arise it you know this has
nothing to do with this it has to do
with with getting these damn automated
calls from hi this is blah blah blah
from credit services no way dude in the
last month I have not had a single call
because of the robot or the Robo killer
app we'll put a link to it it's totally
real its own clothes man it's like you I
asked Reno mortgage on my phone number
it's not even on my phone number Loxton
it has a list of like hundreds of
thousands of phone numbers that are
blocked you can accept them if you want
but it does such a great job of
screening out the nonsense
and it still lets the regular calls
yesterday have phone calls for like I
had like a 2000 and I want to say seven
like Toyota Avalon mm-hmm I still bet I
don't even own that car anymore I still
get calls like you should extend your
warranty yeah you won't anymore I don't
say me so their claim is that it
eliminates something like 85 or 90
percent of of these in the first month
so it learns your call patterns as well
and it starts to filter them out
accordingly you can also add people to
the list if you you're like if it does
get through and you're like I don't what
you had my phone number and I gave it to
you at one point but I don't want you to
have it anymore you're blocked and it
will it will never even get through your
phone as a missed call and it will tell
you which numbers blocks as well so it's
it's a really good app for me so far if
that changes I will let you all know and
the last thing I want to recommend is
another album actually it's an EP they
just call it a collection it's six songs
by our friends and the band brother
Cephas it is a collection it's on
Spotify and iTunes and Apple music and
everywhere else you you listen to music
it's called not that important and I
think today maybe we end the show at the
very end we'll put the single from that
it's called toxic slip and it is the
song has actually been stuck in my head
all morning because I was listened to it
yesterday and I woke up with the song in
my head today so it's a great album
great song by our friends and the band
brother Cephas let's put a link to that
and the show notes as well Ryan what's
been adding value to your life recently
man I've got a few things
um I binge-watched Rick and Morty when I
was in never heard of it what I'm in
Germany I don't know if you'd like a
dude it is it's a cartoon
um but it's like let me just give you
the preface of it okay so you got a
family of four uh husband wife their two
kids a son and daughter uh-huh you have
the mother's father yeah who lives with
them and he's like this drunken mad
scientist and him and his grandson uh
who's relatively new Morty no
now it's been out for a while but
there's only two seasons the third
season is supposed to come out this year
they've already released they released
the first episode of season three on
April Fool's Day how funny is that dude
that's actually pretty genius because
they're like hey Newt you know Episode
one is up and of course people are
thinking oh this is done playing an
April Fool's joke foot actually actually
did actually put it out yeah it's a
reverse April Fool's joke yeah exactly
that's so meta um but it's a genius show
man because it's it's hilarious it's
very vulgar so like it's not really a
kid show I'm not going to put you know
the cartoon even though it's real yeah
it's for adults um so yeah definitely
it's definitely pg-13 um
if not our I mean they don't say the F
word but they say pretty much everything
else right um and then like just some of
the preface is behind like the some of
the storylines um for some of the
episodes or a little bit vulgar but it's
so funny dude and it does this crazy
thing we're like it will tie in um like
different scientific theories like uh
you know other alternate realities
existing and it's just it's really crazy
man so like it's it's baloney for all
intents and purposes like it is not this
is not going to be educational but
you're like people are going to get a
good laugh out of it it's entertaining
you'll enjoy it yeah and it also does
help you think just with some like
really cool science stuff okay I mean I
guess others like that I don't think you
would like I don't know you might dude
you could give it a try it's one of
those where I put it on um I was trying
to get over jet lag I got up at like 2
o'clock in the morning 3 o'clock in the
morning I was in Berlin where I was
asleep I my good good friend Josh Wagner
recommended this show to me uh-huh
and I like put it on for the first
episode and like I was just kind of you
know jet-lagged not really paying
attention but then like halfway through
the second episode I finally clicks with
me I was like the concept of like what
they were doing with the show
and I finally was able to like suspend
that disbelief of took a little while to
get into yeah but it's not one of those
we're like you know watch you know after
the first season you're going to love it
it's like once you get the concept okay
but I went back and rewatched the first
episode because it was like it was so
funny anyway um it is hilarious there's
and there's only like 21 episodes in
there like 20 minutes apiece okay I
think you can find it so it's not a
Netflix
it'll be on Hulu if people have Hulu it
was on Netflix in Germany that's why I
watched it but then when I got back I
tried to watch reruns and I couldn't let
that was on the Lumia so Rick and Morty
hilarious
oh my god dude so so funny um I'm also
I'm gonna recommend skydiving man like
for anyone out there do it like it what
cuz I'll tell you that when I landed I
feel like it are you sure I haven't
talked about this on a previous podcast
I'm pretty sure anyone less then please
consult your doctor before yes god yes
exactly
but what I'll say man is like after I
landed on the ground I had such a good
feeling of like I can do anything like
like you know um writing about a certain
topic or asking for something from
somebody or whatever it may be it's like
all of a sudden I'm like wait a minute I
just sharpened your confidence yeah like
yeah exactly man I was like wait a
minute like I just jumped out of an
airplane and I'm scared to like you know
ask so-and-so for for this one favor
right leg the worst they can do is say
no yeah and that's not going to kill me
it's nothing compared to jumping out of
a plane so you had totally sharpened my
confidence um it's it's a hell of an
experience man I probably won't ever do
it again I'm like I don't think you know
something outweigh either it's expensive
it's expensive and it is kind of a
pointless risk if it wasn't for being in
the moment in Whitefish like I would
never planned it out it was like a
spontaneous we did sleep on it like it
was the next day and I was like okay
like I still feel good about it and yeah
Bryan and his fiancee want to do this so
so yeah I would I'd say
go for it for anyone out there who needs
their confidence sharpened a little bit
the only time I ever skydive is when I'm
on secret government wait I'm I've never
skydive in my life no no I know man I
knew I would suggest you do it but I
know I'm never talking into it and
that's okay man yeah this here's I my
life insurance will not will not allow
me to so it's okay yeah and then the
other saying I
we probably recommended this on a
previous podcast but I've been doing
i've been using the brain octane from
bulletproof yeah and I don't do
bulletproof coffee like MCT oil yeah but
it's like concentrated MCT oil but what
I love about this the the brain octane
is it will make me feel satiated like a
lot longer than like if I had a
breakfast I'd be hungry by noon yeah but
if I put a tablespoon of this in my
coffee in the morning like I'm good to
go to like 2 or 3 o'clock in the
afternoon I want it when I feel hungry I
eat it sound like I don't intentionally
starve myself right but yeah it helps
extend your intermittent fasting yeah
absolutely and I gotta listen so Joe
Rogan is did a podcast episode with Dom
D'Agostino who is a scientist I think
was episode 994 maybe who he's a
scientist who studies the ketogenic diet
with really high fat like like 92% of
his diet is fat well I look at him I'm
like okay what does the scientist guy
look like I google his name he looks
like a Calvin Klein underwear model he's
a scientist well and a lot of has to do
with the ketogenic diet and and 90% of
his diet is fat like this chicken 8% is
protein and 2% of carbs and he goes
there's a lot of the details of it which
sounded crazy to me at first until he
ended blamed in a very scientifically
healthy it's a it's not just healthy
they're they're using it to cure cancer
and and yeah in mice right now and
they're doing some clinical trials or
they've used it to cure epilepsy
terminal epilepsy
to the point where they have no epilepsy
and a bunch of other weird side effects
positive side effect is cured Singh
shingles and herpes and not cured it but
but you no longer do I mean if you have
shingles you no longer are going to
display the you still have the virus but
you won't display the outward symptoms
of it that's the mom yeah the check out
yeah and cold sores and a bunch of other
stuff this diet is I mean seriously
people who have have embarked on this
have put their cancer into remission and
and while other treatments I mean
chemotherapy kills some people it helps
some people too don't get me wrong
there's nothing but but what are you
doing is he's taking a Western medicine
approach toward so not a a woowoo sort
of Eastern yeah you just fast a little
bit and know if he's talking about
macronutrient
allocations and and calorie tracking and
calorie restriction intermittent fasting
in a way that that will help normal
people who also want to stave off cancer
in the long run right and and but then
also people who are predisposed for
cancer or other diseases or epilepsy if
you have seizures this the ketogenic
diet has has cured people of certain
seizures but also pets there are a lot
of pets who have moved over to a key
that people move their pets the kid dies
to cure them of of ailments like cancers
and and and other things it's awesome
but he backs it up with a lot of science
and check it out so what is like um do
you have an example of like a day in the
life of someone who does a ketogenic
diet like what are the meals look like
yeah so you still have to get your the
necessary macronutrients you try to
still consume the normal amount of
calories you would which is both easier
and more difficult with a high-fat diet
because a handful of almonds like a big
handful of almonds 500 calories so we
don't realize that I would you know I'll
buy a bag of almonds on the road and not
realize I just ate 2,000 calories and
minutes right and so a lot of nuts and
seeds so like does he intermittent fast
as water he does because he doesn't I
think twice a week did he did 20 hours
of intermittent fasting twice a week he
also does long fasts for seven days
sometimes but that's different although
that long-term fasting mimics a
ketogenic diet because your body starts
eating fast so the whole idea behind a
ketogenic diet is in by the way I'm no
expert on this but your body typically
most Western diets we most people the
Western diet our body runs off of
glucose sugars basic gray right carbs
sugar etc and in fact protein that
you'ii turn it turns into glucose as
well and so the Western diet we which is
like a fast energy and that's what we
need more and more and we need to eat
more frequently the reason intermittent
fasting or fasting in general helps that
you no longer feel hungry in the
mornings right is because you're
mimicking in a way a part of the
ketogenic diet you're not in ketosis you
be in ketosis you have to be above 0.5
mm millimolar z' and the only way to
test that is through through testing
your blood the blood strips brave and
but but what you're doing is when your
your but you you're shifting your body
to to eat or to be fueled by fat yeah
and the things that he talks about is is
a radically increased mental clarity
through through the ketogenic diet the
the slaking of hunger so you're no
longer hungry the same way you were
before but then when he does eat it's
it's now he doesn't have a because he's
already in ketosis have been in ketosis
for a while he has like a modified diet
worth it's probably closer to 80% fat
which is still really high I mean so
what would his meals would look like
throughout the day he's not just eating
nuts nuts avocados sardines he does a
lot of canned sardines and he actually
goes through it on the podcast a lot he
and then he also supplements with some
ketones as well
supplemental ketones and finds a way to
still get over 2,500 calories a day one
and but also you don't feel that same
hunger anymore and over time once you
want your body actually starts burning
only fat you lose the desire for bread
and pasta no it doesn't even sound
appetizing to you and well once you're
actually in ketosis and so it's not
something I've experimented with
directly I mean I'm probably pretty
close to advice certainly still fueled
by glucose but something I would
certainly consider in the future but uh
there's a biggest thing and for a lot of
people has been weight loss so young
people who are morbidly obese who get on
a ketogenic diet you know hey you see
someone who is 500 pounds and then they
lose all the weight and have all this
extra like floppy skin everywhere and
Joe Rogan so they look like a flying
squirrel yes and I still have something
I mean I lost 80 pounds I have a little
bit of a gut still just because I mean I
can go out in public without a shirt on
until okay but I certainly saw some of
the skin because the way I lost it and
but if you are on a kiddie genic diet
there are examples of people who lose
three four hundred pounds and none of
that extra skin is there the skin
shrinks with this because the way the
body is burning fat instead of trucos so
you'll find I mean I didn't mean to go
down that tangent there no it was a
really good episode and good and I think
other people I applied to value in it as
well yeah I'll have to check it out man
no the yeah let's move on we hold on I
got one more thing yeah already you
already talked about it no I got one
more uh Richard Brendel so he's the
yodel yodeling guy I'll have a link a
hug Sean put a link in the show notes
yeah he's got like just a few things on
out there in the in the streaming music
world um I love yodeling tracks dude I
love like walking around and just like
listening to it and I love accordion too
that's the other thing is I hardly love
accordion anyway so if it sounds like
something he'd be interested in yeah a
look at Richard Rendell he's a pretty
talented guy all right now now it's time
for our new segment we're calling it
weightlifting with the minimalists and
so Ryan you going to start doing bench
presses right here in front of us ready
go
that's where we turn to Twitter and ask
what physical item is weighing you down
and why and we try to help lift the
weight we got this idea from we talked
earlier about Malcolm Fon ta who's
working on the bag with us and he's like
you know a lot of people were yeah with
the minimum stuff they're asking about
physical items a lot of the time and
maybe it would be beneficial if you
started talking to people about what
item right now what one item is weighing
them down so we're at the minimalists on
twitter and i just asked the question
this morning on twitter i'm going to
pull one quickly there's a bunch of
questions here we won't have time to get
to all of them maybe we'll do in that
overtime segment at some point for our
patreon folks but we had some folks
weigh in on what physical item is
weighing you down recently and why and
this one from Julia who who asked or who
said my house with a lawn is weighing me
down mowing the yard really isn't my
thing
I don't know what you would say to Julia
Ryan
but I'm sorry give you that one more
time yeah a house with a lawn is Momo in
her town is weighing her down a house
with the lawn okay so what what's the
thing that is weighing her down it's the
house with a lawn
she said mowing is really it really
isn't my thing and for me we have a
small a very small lawn at our house and
I say mulling isn't my thing either
and so I think there are at least two or
three things you could do here and I
could tell you the three things that
that I would consider were I in your
shoes number one is I would consider
finding someone to pay to mow the lawn
for me dude that is actually
surprisingly affordable it really is
because you get these guys with the you
know eighty thousand dollar 60-inch zero
radius turn lawn mowers right like I
remember when you Colin and I were
living together in Missoula right we had
a pretty big yard to mow yeah and we
were paying someone what like 30 bucks a
month yeah it was it was pretty
affordable I mean for them to come out
there and get it get it done in like No
ten minutes yes
yeah it was it was really quick we're
like if we went and bought a push mower
for 100 bucks or a couple hundred bucks
right and then it would have taken us an
hour hour and a half to cut the lawn
yeah yeah and and we would had to pay
for and then when we left that house who
wouldn't had something to do with
because we knew that was a short-term
solution with those were only at that
house for seven months we didn't want to
invest in a lawnmower for seven months
right it made sense to do it that way
but also our time how could how could I
spin that time if you're spending an
hour an hour and a half mowing the lawn
what's it worth to you to get that time
back room and allocated towards
something creative or to spend time with
your children and so that's one thing is
you can have someone else do it if you
can afford it obviously and then what
else are you going to do with that time
am I asking that question I help you get
the leverage you need or here's the
other thing maybe there's someone in
your house in your house who loves doing
it here's my example Beck's loves mowing
the lawn
I mean loves it like we went out
invested in a lawn mower we stretch them
a couple hundred bucks on a nice lawn
mower and she was mowing the lawn two
days ago in fact I I kid you not she
loves mowing lawn
she was mowing our neighbor's lawn at
the same time because we have this tiny
line it takes her ten minutes if that to
money it's just a little tiny patch of
grass in the back basically that we play
with with Ella in the backyard but the
neighbors have the same size a lot and
so they she was over there mowing their
lawn as well and she loves to do it so
maybe someone else in house loves to do
it and if so great because you don't
love it doesn't mean that someone else
doesn't love doing it here's the third
option maybe the space that you're
living in isn't appropriate for you and
Ryan you live in a place you don't have
to any any yard work right now and
that's pretty awesome you don't have to
deal with it right where there's no yard
work whatsoever or the little bit of
landscaping in the apartment complex
where you are the condo complex that
you're at is is done by the the building
the association there that they all take
care of the little plants or whatever
you don't have to go water anything and
so maybe you need to live somewhere
where someone else takes care of it for
you yeah yeah that's uh that's some good
advice I don't think I wouldn't add
anything that the only thing only other
thing maybe I was thinking
find like a neighbor kid that could use
an extra 10 bucks you know a month or
whatever and just offer you know you
could help you could add value to
someone else's life yeah you suddenly
you already have the lawn mower so may
raise have him have him come over and
mow it yeah dude when I when I would
have anything where I live like this
would happen like when I was married or
whatever but kids would come up like hey
we're shoveling driveways for 10 bucks I
used to do that man yeah brother Jerome
and I we would make a hundred bucks on a
weekend no money we could ever spend we
were 12 years old yeah and then yeah and
like two for me to help out a little kid
like that who's out there like trying to
work like it feels good to like give him
some bucks and so and then oh by the way
my my driveway is shoveled now
absolutely oh yeah you could add some
value to someone else's life that way
they're a bunch of other questions on
here what we'll do we'll have to do a
separate segment at some point over a
patreon also you can hit us up on
Twitter let us know what is weighing you
down we will help you lift the weight
here's a funny one Ryan from Matt D
Avella
the director of our documentary oh if
you had too much marinara sauce I said
what's weighing you down and he said a
200-pound benchpress with no spotter I
don't think that's true man I was the
sauna with him a few days ago we're I
was out in LA and he's out in LA now mac
and bench 200 pounds yeah I felt like I
mean I felt like I was being attacked by
his texts I felt like his texts were
judging me that is grave and so I'm at
geobella but anyway yeah you can hit us
up at the minimalists let us know what's
weighing you down we'll try to help you
out over on on the Twitter's all right
Ryan all right well you asked for them
so here they are here's some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
sighs is Rob calling from Richmond
Virginia I had a comment about some of
the discussions years had not many more
particular podcast regarding debt and
credit cards I agree up with a lot of
things you guys have said about how
credit cards really bad obviously credit
card debt is really really bad with the
incredible interest rates and all that
but one thing I wanted to point out that
I have energy guys discuss is the good
side of using a credit card such as the
buyer protections like where they extend
your warranty or if the product is
stolen for example my dad recently
rented a bike on vacation it was stolen
and ordinarily if you attached you would
have to pay for the bike
Jesus credit card the credit card
company covered it and he was not you
know having to face a couple hundred
dollars to pay for this bike um things
like that you know rewards points or you
know if you're as you know you're
spending it on things like only that you
can afford and you need those points can
be beneficial or travel you know cash
bag things like that so I just thought
that was interesting something to point
out hi this is Tracy from New Jersey and
I'm responding to Amy's dilemma with the
pictures that she had from the passing
of her father this happened to us a few
years ago when my husband's parents both
died within a short span of each other
and we took all of the pictures from
their home in order to try to organize
them for the family what worked really
well for us is I went through the
pictures instead of him because I was
more dispassionate about it the pictures
didn't hold a lot of memories for me and
I think he would have agonized over each
and every photo the first thing I did is
I separated any photo that didn't have
people in it and I got rid of them my
in-laws loved taking pictures of
landscapes and flowers and birds and
they were beautiful but they had no
meaning to us at all I'm sure they gave
hid my in-laws great pleasure but they
didn't hold any meaning for us so those
immediately went the pictures that were
left had people in them and I sat down
with my husband and I said identify the
people so I can write it on the back and
if he didn't know who the people were
the picture went in obviously again held
no meaning for him there were a few that
we reached out to his siblings and said
do you know these people are and if we
could identify them it went into the
keep pile then finally we went to the
key
while and we look for things that were
similar if there were 10 pictures from a
party 9 of them probably went and doing
this over a period of about 2 weeks we
whittled the pictures down about 95% and
the ones that were left
we scanned and we made an album a
digital album and we gave a copy to each
of our siblings this worked really well
it brought up a lot of nice memories and
it saved my husband the agony of going
through each and every picture and I
didn't mind so Amy perhaps a friend or a
relative that wasn't quite as close to
your dad can help you with this and good
luck to you and we're all we're all here
for you hello um this message is for
Andrew from the alignment segment my
name is Jess Blackburn I'm from
Indianapolis Indiana
again this message is for Andrew from
the Lilan segment he was talking about
donating his phone's his Museum of
phones and what to do with them I am
passionate about helping people
especially people with developmental
disabilities and I do that day to day by
working for providers that provide
services and so what my well my company
does is we support individuals with
developmental disabilities on daily
daily basis in their home help them live
on their own and just help their quality
of life enhance their quality of life
and the thing about people with
developmental disabilities that a lot of
people don't see behind scene is that
one of them um don't have a good support
system they don't have on a family and
all of them can't support a job like
most people whether it be physical
limitations or skill limitations
um so a lot of times they don't have
money to buy things for themselves so
people develop those disabilities a good
way to donate your items that you don't
want for example for Andrew Hughes
talking about his
and how they couldn't work I work with
multiple people who are non-verbal and
they use phones for communication
they'll pull up the notes in the iPhone
and type in their what they want to say
to you
since they can't verbally communicate so
having an iPhone for a person for
developmental disability goes a long way
if they're nonverbal so that might be a
good place for an injured to donate his
phones other great things are like TVs
movies clothing there's really nothing
that another person couldn't have so
yeah I just I'd be helpful to let Andrew
know and other people know but a good
place to donate would be people at
developments disabilities you can look
up online any provider the provide
services just in indianapolis alone
there's probably over 3 maybe 500
providers so i could only imagine what
is and only two other cities that are
bigger alright y'all that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also leave us a voice memo you can
email us podcast at the minimalists comm
and if you leave here with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time oh yeah and here
is a song from brother Cephas it's
called toxic slip from their new EP it
is called
not that important
[Music]
you and all this I'm afraid of what I
read so inviting I wonder how it feel
it's not that important now
[Music]
things just my
[Music]
Nanako good stuff it's made up
I'm a well you know you
Rustam traitor Howard really feel so
inviting
I wonder what it costs not that
important now
nothing's ever fine
[Music]
I'm waiting on that call he draws tomato
here it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dan is showing
you
[Music]
and to dock you can
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
doc
you
[Music]